about a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
the German capital Berlin and today
we're looking at the latest developments
in Turkey where a major crackdown on the
media has been taking place in the
aftermath of the failed July the 15th
coup some journalists like jammed under
the editor-in-chief of the centre-left
newspaper Jim Harriet have been forced
into exile meanwhile international media
outlets are also coming under pressure
including a Deutsche Welle team that
recently had its material confiscated
after presenter Michelle Friedman
conducted a critical interview with a
Turkish Minister so today we've decided
here on quadriga to focus on the future
of the freedom of the press in Turkey
and to do just that I'm joined here in
the studio by three excellent analysts
and commentators the beginning with
Michelle Friedman who was as we've
already mentioned with that DW team that
was a victim of harassment in Ankara he
says what happened to Deutsche Welle
steam is clearly an indication that
press freedom in Turkey is more theory
than reality Michelle is nodding also
with us is Alan Posner regular columnist
with the Berlin daily default Alan warns
here in Germany every newspaper article
has to be submitted for authorization so
we should be very cautious indeed about
criticizing other countries and also
today we are joined by go champion Li
she's a freelance journalist in an
academic who says the press was scarcely
free in Turkey before the 15th of July
coup attempt now it is totally under
strict control thank you all for joining
me here today on quadriga I'd like to
begin with you Michelle Friedman because
you were you were in ankara at the heart
of that incident as the deutsche welle
team had its material confiscated after
an interview with a Turkish Minister I'd
like to ask you when the material was
confiscated when you realize what was
happening to what extent did you feel
that you were in an authoritarian state
perhaps even what some people might call
a dictatorial state a state where there
where the freedom of the press no longer
exists I spontaneous
action would have been like this a
German in France and Great Britain I'm
calling the police the police is there
to protect me and ministers not more
than I am NOT less we are on the same
level I'm calling the police because at
least it was a robbery somebody took our
material it was our team the Deutsche
Welle said and paid for this material
and I felt immediately that this is not
an option mmm latest Lee then you know
where you are that you are not anymore
in a democracy that you are not anymore
in country were check and balances for
an individual are practical from this
moment on I understood what happened in
Turkey towards journalists intellectuals
artists name them before the coup and
even more after the cool let's just
bring in girl mainly because you were
nodding I could see you nodding when
Michelle Friedman was talking about the
fact that he didn't feel as though he
had that option to simply phone the
police well I was wondering what would
be the case for instance if that
happened in another in a democratic
country would daughter Leila have the
right to say that not that sure no
that's why I would have called the
police even a minister or press officer
is not allowed to do it I am protected I
imagine that I'm protected by amid but I
imagine more here than that what I felt
in Ankara no administers not allowed
also his press officer who did it is not
allowed the only authority which had the
right to confiscate whatever would have
been the police and if they are doing a
mistake in Germany I would take a lawyer
and we will discuss about this reaction
and decision and this is unimaginable
today however in the case we had to live
through it's interesting because you are
comparing a little bit Germany and
Turkey Ankara and Berlin and Alan Posner
at the top of the show we had a quote
from you where you were saying here in
Germany every newspaper article has to
be subjected to or submitted for
authorization every interview with a
million
say interview good point yeah fair
enough year but you seem to be
suggesting with that quote that the the
this the press freedom applies in the
same way in Germany as it does in Ankara
and vice versa no not in the same way
but mrs. Whitman knows very well because
he had a series of interviews in our
newspaper venoms onto a couple of years
ago where we didn't adhere to this rule
and the politicians knew it or the
people he interviewed knew it but it
never caught on and the reason and the
reason is the politicians want to
control their image I don't know if they
would go so far as to confiscate you
know interviews are already been
Missouri in the can I'm not saying it's
the same thing it's deplorable but what
I am saying is politicians try to
control the image now it would be
unthinkable in America if you did a an
interview as a newspaper with Hillary
Clinton or with the president that they
would say well you have to submit York
with the you know the quotes for
authorization it wouldn't happen or in
Great Britain it's a german thing as
what i'm saying there are differences in
the freedom of the press and the
authority that that that positions have
from country to country let's get going
Billy to comment on those differences
between the freedom of the press those
nuances that are so important they are
very important actually and it shows in
for me I'm really this is a information
that's new for me I didn't know that the
German media may have that right to
check what what you talk with the
politicians actually but in the Turkish
case I think the thing that matters is
the questions i know i i'm not sure how
hard did you get what to put in during
your interview but i think you can you
get a job you can be more critical still
in Germany because South censorship is
more effective now in Turkey I want to
give in response to my dear friend Ellen
as I'm writing in newspapers too and you
just mentioned it this what you were
painting about you
paper is not a must it's an agreement
who nobody really knows why and whatever
it is but we have to make a cut between
an interview for a newspaper where you
are talking to three hours perhaps with
the Minister Prime Minister and you're
changing the questions and the answers
like a post we are doing television and
in Germany and I'm doing TV shows in
Germany nobody nobody ever had the idea
to confiscate and interview on TV on
radio and why because our interviews are
generally all life on tape or even life
and even not there was not one case that
a politician asked the court to decide
that an interview can't be broadcasted
and this is a deep difference in the
examples and I believe that this is in
America this is in Germany and when I'm
listening to the president Erdogan or to
the Prime Minister before the coup they
told us that turkeys democracy yeah but
I have to judge on this values and I
think it was not done let's go John I'd
like to hear you orhan pamuk the Nobel
Prize piece brno the the author who won
the literature prize the Nobel Prize he
came out and he said not just the
freedom of the press but the freedom of
thought no longer exists in Turkey I
need to know is he right I think he's
right especially after the July cooked
attempt I think people are really afraid
this time to tell out that what they
think it's of course before the July
coop attempt there wasn't turkey was not
a democracy already after slowly
gradually after the gezi protests I
think turkey switched sharply to an
autocrat autocracy and adores presidency
was very strong his power was
consolidated etc but after the coop
attempt state of emergency changed
things so freedom of press is not
present but freedom of thought people
are afraid to express their critics and
those who do they simply end up in
prison this is no joke I mean a lot of
friends from Academy from journalism are
and writers novelists are simply peace
activists they're in prison okay so
let's have a let's have a very quick
look let's just to take a quick break
from the debate and look at some of the
figures about the crackdown in Turkey
which has led to Turkey being described
by reporters without borders as the
world leader in imprisoning journalists
and the figures we're going to present
now are supplied by the Committee to
Protect Journalists at least thirty news
related websites were censored more than
100 media outlets were closed and more
than 100 journalists were detained last
year reporters without borders ranked
turkey 150 first out of 180 countries on
its world press freedom index is turkey
carrying out a systematic campaign
against the media it's good question
i'll impose nazar to crack hum to which
down or you know a far-reaching security
measure look um I don't know right but
certain things have to be such there was
a coup attempt there were hundreds of
people killed this coup attempt was
faced down not by an authoritarian
crackdown faced down by the people of
Turkey and to this day even the main
opposition parties support the
government in clamping down on this coup
second thing is true there were hundreds
if not thousands of supporters of the
coup in all in the judiciary in the
media in the MIT in the military many of
them supporters of mr. gülen in
Pennsylvania a radical Islamist Islamic
I'd say preacher now if you consider it
Germany for instance after the 1968
revolt people like me were going on the
streets shouting mouth you to Monroe
that kind of thing though we had beliefs
of order we had tens of thousands of
people not being allowed you know big
being controlled before they were
allowed to take a job
the state and so on and so on so and
that we were nowhere near as powerful as
mr. Gulen whereas the military was with
this could we never attempted a coup
when you think of the his dear
hysterical reaction to the Red Army
Faction the 70s and I think we should be
just a bit careful in the case of Turkey
where there really was a cool with it is
a powerful military where there
obviously was a so-called shadow state
you know so I'm not happy with what's
happening I'm just saying don't forget
it got champion Li what do you say we
don't forget that people do not forget
this of course the killing of hundreds
of people on the coop attempt during the
coop attempt and afterwards is still
going on with these attempts i think it
was horrible but on the other hand peace
activists that that has nothing to do
with the Gulen movement especially
supporters of Kurdish peace process why
are they then arrested what do they have
to and do they have anything in common
with tubular moment they are anti
villainous I mean an academic Anna
journalist who is left wing who is just
critical of the Afghan government could
be blamed as a terrorist what I'm really
curious about what terrorism means now
in Turkey nowadays because it's I think
its definition has become so flexible
that enables are going to do what he has
in mind so and many members of the press
and many members of the media have been
arrested and detained you said that some
of them are your friends people you know
closely just give us an idea of what has
happened to these people of what is
going to happen to these people they
have been arrested and put in jail that
has that's what happened and the thing
is because people no longer believe and
I certainly also do that law is not free
in Turkey no more the course are not
free I think there is some somehow
there's little hope Thank You these
people in prison are they be
tortured are they being abused there are
reports and there are accusations of
torture and but I'm not sure I mean
nobody can go in there for instance the
Ostler done he she's a novelist and she
was on the editorial member team of us
bringing them the kurdish newspaper she
said that i was left without water for
days i was forced to sleep on a very
dirty bed and they didn't give my
medication but afterwards the government
authorities all of a sudden say no we
haven't done that so you can't know
who's telling the truth at the moment
sure I think there is no legitimation
for the coup this is there is no doubt
about that but it's an act of
self-defense this was Jackie's 911 many
people in Turkey argued but we have to
remember that this what is going on
today happened before the coup and was
on the same quality or non quality of
treating people in your country when you
remember all the demonstration last year
the reaction of the government the
reaction of present alga this was enough
this was enough to say this is not the
way how you treat your people in a
democratic process of a position of
peace movements whatever a third
reaction was a third respond I agree and
you said the there are over reactions in
such cases but because of before the
crew the behavior was more or less the
same than after the crew against the
position I'm not so sure if the argument
is really the same one if in the country
something happens like in France
terrorism there is a time of emergency
but in France there is not one newspaper
was closed there are no journalists were
in prison and even they are they would
have their civil rights that's why I
think we have to look at Turkey and we
have a lot of reasons arguments to talk
about
being superior our arguments but at the
end of the day hundreds and thousands
are in prison we don't know how long and
since when and there is one thing Peter
you just mentioned a lot of judges are
now in prison that means no court cases
no judges I'd like to pick up on that
point because we've just been hearing
that it's not just the media it's not
just the press they've been heard that
have been affected by the crackdown
let's have a look at another case here
last week in the southeastern city of
Java kiram police broke up a protest by
teachers some of the 11,000 throughout
the region who were suspended from their
jobs last Thursday the authorities said
the teachers had either supported the
Kurdish PKK rebel group or the Gulen
movement the government says that
movement was behind the July coup
attempt Gulen denies any involvement
there's no difference between the Gulen
movement the PKK and the Islamic state
group but these teachers say they are
not criminals Lake the government
doesn't want secular scientific and
democratic education this man was
suspended for allegedly supporting the
Gulen movement is air21 trying to limit
freedom of speech and expression in
Turkey gudgeon why what is it exactly
does the Turkish government have to fear
from academics and teachers because
there are educators of the next
generation there are still very a lot of
people living in Turkey I mean most of
the people forget that half of Turkey
haven't voted for aired on so these
teachers these academics are responsible
for the next generations and he was very
clear that he doesn't want critical
minds he doesn't he only wants religious
generation so that's why he's I mean
it's it's a total to plan I think it's
not only media freedom is not only
academic it's not if one had once power
and
with that power wants to change the
direction of a country in a religious
way then you can't have em you can't
stand different voices different critics
so he's acting very cleverly and these
people who are teachers of the next
generation are they all also members of
the Gulen movement because this is what
is insinuated this is what is suggested
by the others that they are part of a
conspiracy you are a number of more than
10,000 teachers were fine because they
were believed to be supporters of pay
Kaka the Kurdish moment but I mean the
problem is we don't know the truth yet
the courts are not working effectively
and there is no one who can tell us what
is right and what is wrong the coop has
been how many months have passed and
still it's so foggy and it's everyone
says something and we can't know who's a
supporter of killing supporter of paca
course secularism this state of
emergency of course contribute to this
confusion a lot hmmm because you can
detain people and 49 days without
allowing him or her to see his lawyer or
her lawyer I think you made an
interesting point we are listening the
ghulam is a radical a representative
erratically Islamist my impression is
that the islamization is a part of
present elegans policy if you are
looking and if you are listening how
many arguments suddenly are backed by
religious argument ations if you see
that certain symbols are getting a
political and religion important see we
have to take care that this is also one
of the points we have to take care I
don't say that this is a basic motive of
him to do what he's doing but if you are
looking
what is going on on the streets on and
the country you know that you have to
take care that religion is not again
miss used for political issues allan
poe's now well yeah i disagree with both
of you in that case because if other one
really wanted to have a Islamic
dictatorship in turkey he would not have
broken with the Gulen movement which
yeah we heard him saying that Gulen is
just as bad as is or considering that he
worked with Gulen until four or five
years ago where does that put him if
there was a plan as you suggest to
transform turkey from a semi secular
state into an Islamic state as you are
suggesting then then surely he wouldn't
have broken with with with with Glenn
who helped him get rid of the generals
who helped him get rid of the deep state
in the account agon trials and so on so
I think that by turning against Gulen
actually other one is now much more in
the pocket of the generals than he was
before this is you know part of the
strange consolations where we don't know
who's controlling whom and yeah I'm not
gonna you know suggest that that it's
correct to put thousands of you know to
dismiss thousands of teachers but i will
say that your first answer was right we
really don't know what's happening there
and I don't see a plan i see a terrible
confusion first of all I didn't say
islamization of the country it's more
religious direction i said that's
probably different i mean because
islamization or Islamic country it's
totally have very confusing connotations
i think because there exists a llama
kristair is Islamic state so in a more
religious direction i said and i think
if this doesn't put advanced a war which
unit doesn't tell us that he doesn't
want similar things about from religion
i mean i think they are very alike I
mean why did they do we know today for
instance why did they fall apart why
that's the very simple to big open
question yes and it's very simple and we
don't know it but again I
I think for the Democratic to be a
democratic country to be by human rights
are respected and etc both groups I
think don't are not interested in it's
only a few weeks ago no coup in Turkey
and the authorities didn't handle
situations like demonstrations a
position on the way our democratic state
would have to do and we don't have to to
to forget that because it's a point
which didn't stop it continued it had
perhaps today a pretext to make more
about that but elegans governments were
not on the quality scale we are asking
to respect the positions respect people
who are not accepting that you are the
president it's a democratic right let's
get everybody valid a chance to respond
by running out of time yeah actually
yeah you're right of course but if
Germany had a war on its borders like
they have with Syria if we had millions
of refugees as they have in Turkey if we
had a civil war it was the PKK who
started the more it wasn't a de 1 and if
we had the deep state generals
conspiring to reintroduce chem ilysm
then I don't know whether we would be so
this doesn't legitimate we sitting here
in Berlin are saying we can live with
this mm-hmm your copy of thousands in
prison gentlemen you are in the trouble
I'd like to bring things too slowly to a
close and ask you the following question
we've seen what's happened in Turkey and
reasoning the last couple of months
there's been a coup initially then
there's been a crackdown an interesting
question is how should the West respond
to this how should Germany respond to
this should Germany and should we
respond by waving our fingers taking the
moral high ground and say we don't
accept this sanctions and so on or
should we keep channels of communication
open Ellen keep challenge of
communication open no sanctions engaged
with Turkey and try to drag them back
into Europe cook them I remember this
if you drift G deal with everyone and
how this actually move of you of
European powers contributed to his power
before the election so I would expect
the West European countries to
contribute to a demo Democratic Turkey
where human rights are respected where
freedom of thought is not a sin etc okay
look Peter we are communicating with
countries like Russia and China why not
with turkey and communications every
time better than not to talk one of the
ways we can communicate is not the
election is often that mr. elder one is
not listening to the West any long it
can be it could be it will be but that's
not the reason why we are not saying
what we believe it okay we're gonna to
leave it there i'm gonna say thank you
to all three of my guests for joining me
today great stuff a week with a new
plenty of food for thought on the debate
about press freedom in Turkey after the
coup if you've got something to if you
want to share the discussion with us
then do join us a social media on the
internet until next week bye bye just